hey everyone thank you for tuning in to
this conversation about interdependent
capitalism this is a book that was
published by several of our friends that
we've had on the show before doctor Joon
Yoon Jeremy Yuen and Conrad Yoon the UN
family foundation and interdependent
capitalism tells a very important story
and we will actually be breaking down
some of the notes that we've made
throughout the book and why it's really
important and you can find all the info
in the bio below but I'm just gonna
we're just gonna read what's on the back
to give you an idea before we start the
story we're telling as simple as humans
have globalized Family Values have not
scaled well not so many lifetimes ago we
lived in contrives where our interests
were aligned according to the principles
of inclusive fitness unfortunately those
principles are maladapted to our modern
era as fake news fake foods and fake
politicians endemic in our society are
catalyzed by the low alignment of
interests among strangers we wrote this
book to help the world reimagine new
types of social political and economic
institutions for the global village the
social contract of the future will be
based on the principles of inclusive
stake holding and vested interest in the
success of others attributes that were
inherent in the inclusive fitness of our
pre-historic social systems the time has
come for interdependent capitalism this
is one of the best books I have ever
read
seriously
okay let's explore this together all
right and I have a good camera angle for
this so we can make it really easy for
us to explore together all right so I
want to start by just going through some
of the main points along the way and we
can discuss as we journey through it I'm
gonna do my best to get through as much
of it as we can so it might be somewhat
longer video but it's very important as
there's a lot of important content in
here that I want to review with you okay
so in the prologue the word go young
Korean for hometown a sense of
tenderness
we took care of each other largely
according to our degree of genetic
relatedness what evolutionary biologists
call inclusive fitness we were fed
informed and governed by those who had
our best interests at heart
energy increases the entropy of systems
most humans were once frozen in one
geographical space for an entire
lifetime
we now bounced all over the globe over
the millennia of the strong stable bonds
of our kin tribes were replaced with
weaker transactional interactions among
strangers the nuclear family has
replaced the kin tribe as the integral
social institution organized around
inclusive fitness nuclear families
closely related to each other within the
household live in communities of other
nuclear families where the genetic
relatedness between households is low
this has fundamentally changed the
day-to-day calculus of social
interactions in short our biological
evolution has not kept pace with our
cultural evolution over and over we
expect strangers to act like they are
our kin and over and over we are
disappointed when they do not
these words are really resonant with me
global inclusive fitness as species
we've been managing the tension between
the social progress that occurs when we
live and work in ever larger groups from
tribes to villages to Taos the cities to
nations and ultimately to today's
globally interconnected cyberspace
replacing our lost sense of the ancient
ancestral home and tribe with
institutional innovations the Empire
that church the nation in the
corporation are all examples of
institutions we have created to replace
some or all of the functions of kin
tribes a system of vested interest in
others to replace can based inclusive
fitness as the essential social contract
kin skin in the game love this one here
too you can see it at the very bottom
here that I wrote at kins skin in the
game love that one too
ok this part here a doctor chooses the
most profitable procedure over the one
most likely to benefit a patient a
politician betrays the public trust by
favoring a well financed special
interest a corporate board puts its own
interests above those of the
shareholders and employees Family Values
have not scaled well as we have
globalised as you can tell this is
already hitting on some of the most
important conversations of our time if
not the most important conversation of
our time
it's a very important book very
important and how we update the code how
we have this discourse and how we update
the code all right
the code of civil civilization so
misalignment meets capitalism in a way
the kardashians and high fructose corn
syrup are really the same phenomenon the
inevitable outcome of a race to the
bottom line when misalignment meets
capitalism the time has come for a
revolution in our social contract unless
addressed this evolutionary lag error
between our biological factory-settings'
tuned to the prehistoric era and the
realities of the modern environment will
continue to incentivize abusive
behaviors promote further mutual
misappropriation for asymmetric games
robots algorithmic incentives can be
designed to mimic the kin altruism of
mom can we make the algorithmic altruism
of mom and embed that into our
artificial intelligence systems is a
very interesting question
inclusive steak holding inclusive
fitness new social DNA encoding
inclusive steak holding into the new
human social contract creating new
social DNA to mimic the inclusive
fitness of our tribal past is a
necessity
imagine entirely new types of social
political and economic institutions
based on inclusive stake holding
congruent goals and a vested interest in
the success of others
imagine the possibilities can we truly
and authentically tie the success of
teachers to that of their pupils tie the
success of health insurance food and
media companies of any industry to that
of customers they serve can we tie the
success of elected officials to that of
their constituents find ways to include
other stakeholders such as future
generations in the environment and those
who have no voice envisioning the
emergence of many models that will
enable this inclusive stake holding
social algorithms designing them for
inclusive stake holding that mimic the
bio bio algorithms of inclusive fitness
again social algorithms for inclusive
stake holding that mimic the bio
algorithms of inclusive fitness
all right how we got to now can try
five decades of life had gone by in a
blink a thousand years adds up to just
20 of those 50-year blinks one blink is
50 years time goes by so fast ten
thousand years of recorded human history
is 20 of those blinks the span
considered in this book is 200 blinks of
an eye so one more time
so one blink is fifty years life goes by
that fast five decades of life a
thousand years is 20 of those blinks and
ten thousand years of recorded history
is two hundred blinks
it's very important time goes by so fast
okay
evolution tends to select altruistic
behavior sometimes even at the expense
of one's own welfare when they are
associated with a net positive outcome
from the perspective of the kin group
a life of service to the global Kim
group Hamilton's rule it's a
mathematical model behind kin selection
the higher degree of genetic relatedness
the higher the Darwinian payoff for
altruistic behaviors this is why we see
that your mother your father and your
family members your nuclear family are
much more likely to do commit altruistic
behaviors towards one another because
that's a high degree of genetic
relatedness there is a higher Darwinian
payoff for that
kin selection predicts the selection of
otherwise inexplicably hate behaviors
such as those that are detrimental to
oneself of beneficial to others in our
kin group
so this is important metropolis redesign
you social Aldi social tea is the
highest level of organization of animal
social tea use social tea is the highest
level of organization of animal social
team defined by features such as
cooperative brood care overlapping
generations living together and a
division into reproductive and non
reproductive groups
as an example helping the Queen give
birth to more sisters propagates one's
genes more than reproducing oneself and
this is females with what looks like
ants bees and wasps
thus a new social species the queen and
king often do all of the reproducing
while the sterile workers organize into
a labor force that supports the overall
hive the degrees of cooperation
self-sacrifice among this high men hope
Terra are remarkable so there's very
interesting biological examples as well
to look at here eusocial insects account
for a disproportionate percentage of the
Earth's biomass up to half in some
regions social insects are at the
ecological centre interesting
okay Jin diaspora and social entropy
a house naturally divides and the
divided houses keep dividing the
division dispersal and genetic
fragmentation of kin tribes are features
of social evolution not bugs
they promote diversity intergroup
competition and mimetic parallax that is
the human tendency to see better when
offered multiple vantage points and
we're going to get to memetic parallax
later in the importance of that
collisions between tribes with little
genetic alignment became more frequent
and relative strangers were forced to
contend with one another on the other
hand trading of ideas and goods are also
began to flourish this is with social
entropy
having access to more people can
increase the probability of finding
better partners in life and in business
okay
the category of self-dealing easiest to
define includes corruption and treachery
the explicit violation of an oath or vow
of duty this could be a city employee
who takes a bribe when awarding a
construction contract there by
prioritizing personal gain over public
duty or it could be a corporate CEO who
invests the company's cash in a cousin
owned business on non market terms so
we're experiencing this broken code with
this increase in self dealing and we
have to fix it we have to repair it
updated
all right these actions are not
necessarily aligned with the bosses or
the company's best interest because he
has an incentive to book a flight that
will add to his frequent flyer miles
this is with an employee that is
participating a Flickr flyer program but
traveling for work corporate leaders are
accused of enriching themselves at the
expense of shareholders political
leaders are accused of dealing for
themselves at the expense of citizens
the problem is endemic everywhere that
humans have a duty to others
what old code is manipulating with
asymmetries of information asymmetries
of information introduced one
significant vector by which voluntary
transactions can be win-lose whichever
party has the most information has the
greatest latitude to cheat with the
cigarette industry's campaign of active
disinformation that denied the
carcinogenic effects of smoking is well
known it is hardly exceptional similar
tactics employed by big food big data
and many more not the least which is big
government
a kind act between relatives promotes
inclusive fitness and motivates both the
actor in the recipient to expand the PI
as a wave to drive win-win outcomes
entirely different type of win-win
vested interest of kin skin in the game
it allows a person to win from an
inclusive fitness perspective by virtue
of another person's winning kin skin in
the game incentivizes cooperative
behaviors altruistic behaviors that
enabled win wins were likely far more
prevalent in a genetically aligned
community than in today's community of
strangers communities now are largely
silos of nuclear families living among
other families with whom they share low
genetic alignment and we have this great
over interest over investing in our
nuclear children in an under investing
in ourselves our communities and the
world this helps explain the explosion
of helicopter parenting and over
investment in children commonly observed
today they are so focused on their kids
that they might miss a social gathering
rather than miss their son's baseball
game people are over investing in their
kids and under investing in their
neighbors
our blood relatives are less likely to
self deal in their interactions with us
than kin strangers as the saying goes
blood is thicker than water
we live over twice as long as our near
ancestors did even 200 years ago
we've lost the foundation of our social
architecture ten tribes so we need to
incentivize vested interest in others
create a system of vested interest in
others to replace inclusive fitness as
the essential social contract right
there right here we're already talking
about the solution it's difficult to
figure out how exactly to do so but we
have already started to identify some of
these pressing conversations
and again all the links to
interdependent capitalism can be found
in the bio
of this video to bolt the website also
to the Amazon book link and the Palo
Alto Institute link
jeromy's ban wjm and Jr's website as
well ok again one of the most important
conversations of our time this is why
we're doing this long-form discourse
with you about the importance of this
book and even if you don't purchase the
book at least hearing us have a
conversation about it here is very
important between you and I we are
having this conversation and then you
can go and have more of this
conversation with people around you
I highly recommend still actually
purchasing the book and having it at
home with you as well
sharing it with people in the physical
world to besides its digital content
alright chapter three the stewardship
that held tribes together was supplanted
by the leadership of kings and emperors
leader was less incentivized to put the
interests of the people before his or
her own interests
we have created a social fabric
codification towards self-dealing
corruption oppression and self-dealing
where the rule not the exception
tyranny could be manipulated of nepotism
ruling over the people instead of on
behalf of the people developed a system
of vested interest in the people
commensurate to the inclusive fitness of
ten tribes none of them that's what we
need inclusive fitness of kin tribes on
a global village scale
after centuries of nepotistic leaders
who gave the world to their sons a story
of a God who gave His only Son to the
world offered a powerful antithesis
the story caught on
story prompted one of the most unique
events in the evolution of human
civilizations the resetting of the
calendar the birth of Christ marked an
effective year zero from which to
measure all time
Bills of exchange were important not
only because they made it possible for
commerce to take place over long
distances which facilitated trade in the
case of a corporation the brains the
shareholders may or may not align with
the muscles the company's management and
directors when this alignment doesn't
exist
corporate failure is inevitable thus not
long after its invention the corporation
became the newest institutional vessel
for abuse of the people
the problem is famously framed by Karl
Marx who spoke of the exploitation of a
proletarian worker class by the owners
of capital who extracted the lion's
share of the value produced and left a
bare minimum to the workers sounds quite
familiar
this is why we see median income
stagnating while GDP continues to
increase in places like the United
States
again the universal basic assets the
inclusive global village
organized labor in order to bargain more
effectively for an equitable share of
the production returns okay
new codes for more effective prosperity
the tension between capital and labor
goes on does not everyone feel that
there is an evil at work which needs
remedy does not the constant occurrence
of strikes and the rise of vast and
powerful organizations of workman show
that there is some profound unfitness
in the present customs of the country to
the progress of affairs if the masters
insist on retaining their ancient
customs if they will shroud their
profits in mystery and treat their men
as if they were another class of beings
whose interests are wholly separate and
opposite I see trouble in the future as
in the past
I hope to see the time when workmen will
be to a great extent their own
capitalist I believe that a movement of
workmen towards cooperation in the
rising of capital would be anticipated
by employers admitting their men to a
considerable share of the profits
the corporate mind and muscles are
aligned the effective use of stock
options for all employers is a
significant element of the mix that made
up Silicon Valley and the
entrepreneurial juggernaut it has become
to help fuel the Information Age and
there's more we can do to make it even
more inclusive stake holding
the invention and growth of the Internet
held out the promise of a boundless and
inclusive future things like digital
equity open source projects creating a
new paradigm for the world of work
horizontal and distributed rather than
hierarchical and centralized systems
Silicon Valley companies are now being
exposed as the latest institutions that
don't serve the public's interests as
well as they serve their own clique
baiting
to maximize profits and misusing
consumer data reflect a company over
customer philosophy again reflect a
company over customer philosophy
corporation is exhibit a grow or die
tendency incentive structures to replace
inclusive fitnah inclusive fitness is
what we need to develop meet the new
boss same as the old boss samples
demonstrate where recurring theme unless
first order alignment issues are
addressed solutions to second-order
problems will only create derivative
ones the central story of mismanaging
our transition from the inclusive
fitness of the tribal era to modern
times
each of us is both the cause and the
victim of the ills we face we'll get to
this more later the good and the evil in
each of us the race to the bottom line
we are all responsible for the
transition back to inclusive fitness
race to the bottom line chapter four
change the matter most the evil
stepmother effect take food for example
until the modern age our food was
produced and prepared for us by someone
who had our best interests at heart our
mother's food largely comes from people
who care about themselves first and
about a second in the modern world the
food industry being a secondary priority
is a dangerous position for us to be in
and yet there we are
make us eat more or to save on the cost
despite doubts about the effects on our
well-being our food system has shifted
from being a high alignment system
during the Kin Tribe era to a low
alignment system today fast-forward to
the past century where the vast majority
of people in industrialized countries
and elsewhere sourced foods not through
their own hunting and gathering but from
a global agro industrial complex
processed foods not just bags of potato
chips in Kansas soda but also baby
formula and energy bars are engineered
to appeal to our ancient cravings for
sugar fat and salt even fresh produce is
the outcome of market driven
optimization with fruit and vegetable
varieties bred for appearance transport
ability and of course taste
misalignments in our food industry
self-dealing actors can hijack
evolutionary inclinations to their own
advantage and this is this this folklore
tale of the evil stepmother
the winners christen commodification of
life can't we call out bad behaviors
regulate them and shame them and make
them go away maybe in an ideal world we
would want a system that selects for the
production of products information
services of maximum inherent value at
the lowest cost
Tinh altruism plus free market
competition is a race to the top ok
so where we are today a world in which
people largely produce products
information services that prioritize
their external value their trading or
sales value over the inherent value as
we fall in rank from number one in our
mom's life to number two in a stranger's
life and so many of our life domains
approves a phenomenon called
commodification which is the creation of
things for their trading value star near
impossible to keep extractive capitalism
and check the negative feedback loop
that would keep violators in check is
not strong enough to deter exploitative
behaviors
competition if anything selects for
lowest costs which will be associated
with lower inherent value the system
selects for maximum commodification at
the lowest cost associate the lowest
inherent value students face increasing
pressure to learn not for the inherent
value of learning but with a focus on
the external value the commodification
of that effort in competing for college
admission virtues once pursuit for its
own stake by contrast virtue signaling
is the commodification of virtue cars
were once bought for transportation now
the signalling value of automobiles
often exceeds the mechanical value
clothes used to close a person now
fashion is about signaling people used
to live life itself now they too often
attend events or travel for the purpose
of promoting their personal brand on
social media
language might once have been used
predominantly to convey truth but now it
is far more often used to tell a story
the system self selects for extractive
and exploitive institutions if we force
one media company to use less clickbait
another will use more in order to pick
up the others market share in a way the
Kardashians and high fructose corn syrup
are really the same phenomenon a race to
the bottom line when misalignment meets
unbridled capitalism no matter how many
times we rerun the simulation called
society the system will eventually
select for fake news about fake heroes
endorsing fake foods
another interesting theory here in bed
mom when conveying information to be
part of the code update
people who act with our best interest at
heart have been increasingly replaced
with people who act with their own best
interest at heart this change promotes
the evolution of institutions towards
prioritizing commodification extraction
and exploitation over inherent value to
the people there is a line behind that
tree or don't drink that water it was in
the service of their tribe share genetic
interest to communicate those things a
culture of storytelling to convey
information useful for survival
today communications technologies of
social media enabled genetic strangers
to control most of our information flow
their self-interest is to use
information to exploit their audiences
to maximize their own fitness
ooh digital social gluttony is
debilitating it's what we're all going
through right now with the massive use
of social the vast majority of
information is actually noise
masquerading as information intended to
dupe the public in the service of
extractive capitalism with very few
exceptions the media today draws our
attention to a seemingly endless parade
of remote threats that are not in our
immediate vicinity and therefore are
mostly irrelevant to our evolutionary
fitness like our food the interactions
encouraged by digital media are designed
to be heavy on stimulation and low on
nourishment processed information is
harmful to the - processed food is to
the body damn
an endemic of digitally enabled social
gluttony that is every bit as
debilitating as the obesity epidemic
digitally enabled social gluttony hmm
should stop accessing our phones 150
times a day
prehistoric males who did not
instinctively respond to visual cues
about potential mates would face adverse
evolutionary selection an organism that
does not rubberneck at signs of carnage
is ignoring useful cues about a threat
in their vicinity which could lead to
adverse selection today the
entertainment industry lures viewers
with manufactured scenes involving sex
and violence then the she's incentivized
to exploit our hardwired tendency to
rubberneck at such queues our innate
tendency to pay attention to status our
positions within the social pecking
order affect access to resources mating
opportunities and many other elements of
evolutionary success
players often play their entire careers
for a single team and we're fixtures in
the civic life of their town this is
sports now that was entertainment the
country is wealthier yet the sport has
also priced out many casual fans from
spending a season with the team Doudna
large part the increasing variety of
entertainments are available it is also
partly related people relocating around
the country for various reasons free
agency players also began to relocate
around the country at dizzying rates
since the players identity is rarely
tied to town for more than a brief stint
fan adoration doesn't last much longer
than a summer fling baseball attendance
is near an all-time high as our revenues
but ask 100 kids in San Francisco today
to name the starting lineup of their
local team they probably could not name
more than five players that degree of
apathy would have been unthinkable 50
years ago ritualized non-lethal
competition is common among social
species and human social systems exhibit
ritualized competitions that result in
rank sorting rank through competition
enables the development of dominance
hierarchies that feed into secondary
social behaviors including rank based
mating resource distribution cooperation
getting very much deep into the biology
into our biology of our social primate
tendencies
hierarchies and mating status all
interplay into this conversation
check
a sense of collective affiliation in
19th century America began to develop
towards teams and athletes based on what
city one lived in and what university
one attended an increasing sense of
alienation and decreasing sense of
community due to the replacement of
height aligned kin tribes with low-lying
communities of genetic strangers
sporting leagues were more than happy to
provide an emotional South of
affiliation however fleeting they
desperately needed to find common ground
somewhere somehow because we felt so
distance from our kin origins of human
social evolution so we found them in
sports
a sense of soullessness is usually a
good barometer of whether an institution
has turned into a low alignment
commodity you sports arguably too much
effort and attention to their children
again that revisiting theme rather than
anything that remotely resembles the
neighborhood life is no different from
the nepotism of Imperial self dealers
cue the rug rat race among modern
parents the share affiliation of youth
sports fills the emotional void created
by the destruction of the neighborhood
sense of community families being drawn
towards eSports also draws them farther
away from their physical neighbors
increasing the sense of neighborhood and
alienation that makes you sports feel
like an attractive alternative attending
their kids sporting events including
those that take them to remote locations
has become a pastime of parents to the
exclusion of other social activities
including seeing one spouse between
Friday afternoon and Sunday evening such
priority on our own nuclear families
children that we lose even our time with
our spouse for it
and our neighbors a lot of this is about
filling these voids with these kin
tribes that we don't have anymore
filling it with entertainment with
sports
the inverse relationship is evident
place like Silicon Valley which uses
work community liberally but struggles
to form strong ones people wave at each
other with five fingers in their
immediate neighborhood with one finger
during their commute and with five
fingers or like this I guess and with
five fingers when they entered the
drop-off circle at their kids schools
other status change industries humans
are innately wire to attune to not only
status but status changes such
activities are the lure of games or
sports fun are sent particularly when
involves status elevation also known as
winning
demes are called great if there are many
lead changes status changes and dramatic
if a status change occurs against all
odds in a late-game
some people are addicted to checking
score updates for the favorite teams top
25 college football rankings have
changed since the previous week topped
40 song rankings were updated American
Idol occurs when a singer whom Gatti's
has been led to believe is of lower
status undergoes the status
transformation while performing a single
song downwards status movements such as
when a celebrity hits a rough patch also
sells the newspapers to a hungry public
the gossip industry is a status change
industry
gossip industries of status change
industry the human mind seems
voyeuristically drawn to undulating
storylines of status change in books
plays and movies the mood changes in
scenes of Shakespeare's Romeo and Juliet
can be described as alternating between
low and high status street brawl
intervention by the prince romeo mopes
meets Juliet learned she's a Capulet
status change is considered a tool not
only for drama or tragedy but for
improvisational comedy - status update
faces many things to be about and ways a
Facebook page is a signalling device for
status how many friends we have who our
friends are what cool thing we did over
the weekend were all our status
attributes most powerful place in all
social media today is a box near the top
of Facebook page simply labeled as
status update what is that status update
what's on your mind what's the status
update its social signaling Oh I'm high
on the hierarchy I travel a lot I have
great work I look fantastic
etc
mortgage lending as housing bubbles for
mortgage lending drift towards risky
loans such as subprime lending at
exactly the least opportune time and too
often lenders try to squeeze out the
last of the profits of a boom period
knowing they will only partially bear
the consequences if their loans default
the bank executives pocketed the games
on the way up and on the way down the
losses were disproportionately borne by
shareholders borrowers and the public
taxpayers too were playing the same game
many of the losses were passed on to
Freddie Mae Fannie Mae Freddie Mac
Fannie Mae or other financial
institutions that had to be bailed out
by the government
in other words the home-buying public
was partially able to socialize their
losses when the music stops everyone
passes the blame to someone else
no one ever admitted I did it not for a
single buck of it when people are able
to capture the upside of investment but
socialize the losses they tend to take
excess risk in exchange for higher
personal returns again this is
asymmetries pocketing gain socializing
losses buying a house there is a
trade-off between getting the deal done
and getting the deal done at the best
price stampede of self-expanding beefs
both examples of race to the bottom line
incentive structures are hardly
exhaustive there's perversity of the US
healthcare system the Google opioid
epidemic for an indication of the litany
of misaligned incentives that plagues
the industry
notes in the secret of our success
all-pro social institutions collapse
over time at the hands of self-interest
stampede of self-expanding beasts there
we go earlier we described how increased
social entropy was the first-order
phenomenon that led to a second-order
phenomenon such as reduced alignment of
interest and increased relationship
liquidity these issues contributed to
third order phenomena which we
summarized as evolutionary mal adoption
of the social political and economic
behaviors of institutions and
individuals the race to the bottom line
was a fourth-order phenomenon
race to the middle it's a possibility of
revolts including those which leads
which heads end up on the chopping block
is evident to those in power thus to
some extent the oppressors have a vested
interest in putting the brakes on a
runaway race to the bottom not because
they have a sense of justice but to save
their own necks even in this situation
the power vested self-interest is at
work
the Byzantine reflects in medieval times
such protection might have taken the
form of a castle topped with battlements
and surrounded by a moat this is an
organization institution it gains power
as a National Center to protect that
power in the status quo powerful
incumbents have learned to use
complexity as a barrier against
competition
the Byzantine reflex refers to systems
that are characterized by tendency to
self evolve towards greater complexity
and obfuscation in a way that favors the
asymmetric beneficiaries of the status
quo aka all of the old code that we live
in
self-expanding beefs the product of the
health care system is not health care
but old people who need more health care
big food produces fake news about fake
foods that increases demand for more
fake food the product of the media is
ignorant and confusion which creates a
demand for more media for the purposes
of book any self-dealing institutions or
system that was designed to serve the
people but has mutated to serve itself
by exploiting the people will hereby be
referred to as a beast any institution
that has self engineered runaway
feedback loops in its favor at the
expense of the people will be referred
to as a self expanding beast
so these beasts can engineer the social
fabric in their favor to stay in power
the more consumers feed on clickbait
news and drink high fructose corn syrup
flavored drinks the more they empower
the very companies that are exploiting
them
the self-dealing media and food
companies in turn get richer and are
able to spend more dollars to bait
consumers forming a vicious cycle in
essence these companies turn into
self-expanding beasts that grow ever
larger at the expense of the people
the fresh has essential set partly right
when they pointed out the alienation of
modern men compared to our ancestors we
modern humans are systemically
disconnected alienate if you will from
our neighbors the natural world around
us our leaders the food we eat pretty
much anything but our pets and the
success of our children both of which
have become the subject of almost
unbounded attention and investment
our factory settings buys towards
exploiting strangers reciprocal altruism
and trusting Kin Kin altruism
furthermore reciprocal altruism has a
flaw it assumes that both sides have
insight and reality information
asymmetry as well as hardwired
preferences attraction of porn violence
sugar gossip can be mined
moreover the feed-forward nature of the
growth of the self expanding piece
allows them to invest in better ways to
increase and exploit asymmetries
all right this is interesting solidarity
and solidarity okay Chapter seven
it's possible that humans are headed to
become the tenth known example of a
species in the animal kingdom evolving
from a social system of solidarity to
one of solidarity one driven far more by
individual self-interest than
interpersonal interests hmm it would
take a very long time for the evolution
of the biological code underlying human
social systems to revert to one that is
well adapted to solitary
and nor is it evident that such shifts
would prove beneficial in the long run
in the meantime the leg air between
modern cultural evolution and our
biological factory settings produced
millennia of dysfunction where
individual self-interest Trump's
interpersonal interests as the operating
system level of human society
as people feel betrayed by or alienated
from others they begin to self deal in
so doing they alienate others further
propagating the vicious cycle in every
case that other is ourselves in kin
tribes of your we balance taking
personal responsibility with taking
responsibility for each other
following Hamilton's Robert ileum brain
executes the default setting by taking
less responsibility for those around us
so we can focus more personal
responsibility on ourselves what results
is a self expanding cult of the self
movement in such a system the
marketplace for psychology neologism
selects its own self expanding taxonomy
words that once involved the second
person are now used increasingly to
describe first person concepts advocacy
used to mean speaking up for others in
schools not teach self-advocacy
mindfulness used to be being mindful
of others but now it's a part of a
self-help personal enrichment movement
we live in a world with self-service
stations and take self-guided tours
where we take selfies next time you go
to a bookstore marvel at how large the
self-help section is and how much it has
grown during your lifetime compare it to
the size of the help others section at
the bookstore what helped other section
you might well ask exactly
the word empathy is defined as the
capacity to understand what another
person is experiencing
from within the frame of reference of
another person even today there is no
word to denote the feeling of seeking
empathy these are the neologisms we need
in psychology 2.0 so that we can build
this interdependent capitalism this
global kin village a new word for
seeking empathy there's going to be
plenty more of these if an empathizer is
one who empathizes what term describes
the recipient of empathy an empathy
what the empathizer intended to do with
that piece of understanding says nothing
about that when someone's empathizing
will they use that information on behalf
of the empathy or on behalf of their own
self-interest one outcome of the
Internet age is that many institutions
know more about people than people know
about themselves they are data gathering
machines masquerading as service
industries
they use and sell that data to maximize
their own economic gain at the expense
of the people again misaligned
incentives in the tech and social media
space it's about that intention economy
and the business plan and selling ads
rather than actually leveraging these
beautiful data's on behalf of us to
maximize what we want
one could make the case that the sum
total of all the hero's journeys in the
world has gone must exactly tube or Pole
to the point we act by society today
what if our possessions of being the
hero slaying the beast and being
transformed as a central contributor to
our current dystopia it's a big one so
maybe our hero's journey
obsession created this dystopia hmm
created the issues that we see have
great duality and separatism we are all
both good and evil it's not I'm evil you
were good I'm good you're evil we're
both good and evil and we have to start
acknowledging that but it's hard because
the gray area doesn't sell in all the
entertainment the black and white cells
it's easy it's also cognitively easy
this global petri dish of misaligned
incentives that is today modernity
what about humans are we doggy dog
people or we are good innocent people
who bask in the illusion of domesticated
bliss while displacing the evil onto a
system that we disparage but nonetheless
feed into and thus are part of typically
what we do I'm good I'm good I'm good
systems bad no no we feed into it it's a
reflection of us we're all responsible
for it each of us is simultaneously the
beast and the hero the good and the evil
the problem and the solution in
separatism we identify ourselves as the
good people we identified the opposing
side as inherently bad people
within a nuclear family the human
experience is characterized by
unconditional love service of sacrifice
these behaviors are programmed and
promoted by the 50 percent genetic
vested interest that we have they have
in each other while the husband and wife
are not typically genetically related to
one another they share the reproductive
bye-bye a programming a mutually vested
genetic interest in their progeny that
promotes a love service fairness a
sacrifice over the generations however
the shared genetic vested interest is
diluted more quickly than you might
realize
grandchildren have one-fourth their
genes in common great-grandchildren only
1/8 after 10 generations the degree of
genetic correlation among descendants is
as low as point zero zero zero nine in
other words their genetic strangers
assuming 20 years between generations
the original nuclear family spawns a
network of strangers in a short 200
years
we all start with the original
experience of our mother's unconditional
love in utero and later experience the
extractive behavior of strangers we
first become aware of light when we exit
the tunnel of unconditional love from
that moment forward we become
increasingly aware of duality a moment
is worth a good cry
we can see each other's Epocrates but be
blind to our own in reality we are all
mixed parts of good and bad yet
something is made to see the world in
black and white made us believe that
there are separate heroes and monsters
according to philosophy represented by
the yin and yang symbol all aspects of
existence flows from this cycle of
opposing forces including flow itself
independence and interdependence are the
yin and yang of human coexistence
neither extreme can stake a claim as the
optimum modality for human social social
team
a swing back to tribalism as a rejection
of the hug of globalization an embrace
which has increasingly become being
performed with knives being held behind
backs
so this is based on the yin-yang we
should be at the forefront of the rise
of this counter force the counter
cultural swing back to tribalism would
restore balance interesting
rather than healing the wounds of
alienation today's tribal isn't throw
salt in them so where is this damn
transformation we were promised where is
the apotheosis haven't we gone on enough
pilgrimages attended enough burning
man's and disturbed enough Amazonians
about their strange bruise AKA Wasco to
find whatever it is we were seeking how
is that every time we set our compass
for home we find ourselves back in the
wilderness seven billion people in the
back seat want to know are we there yet
we are all just a little bit tired can
we just 3d print the Holy Grail we are
or a little bit tired want that global
kin village inclusive stake holding and
interdependent capitalism
but we need the code updates this is the
journey that we go through the term Holy
Grail since become synonymous with an
unattainable goal that is sought for its
great significance the answers are right
in front of us that's because seen
through wider lens the arc of human
experience as we know it has been
nothing more than an epitaph Annamma non
of our search for something new to
replace the inclusive fitness of the
tribal era as the rhythm of our shared
existence it's doable finally bring the
inclusive ethos of the kin village to
the global village thus we have an
opportunity before us an obligation of
epic proportions be this holy grail of
code updates of the kin village with
inclusive ethos and we have the global
village with self dealing now has
evolved we need to bring the inclusive
ethos to the global village part three
race to the top chapter nine revolution
the social contractor written stories
could outlive their storytellers and
compete with descendants stories
nicholas copernicus
transformed a convoluted geocentric
model of planetary motion into the
elegant heliocentric model that we have
today nothing short of earth-shattering
this was in 1549 when Copernicus said
that the earth is not the center of the
universe the earth simply orbits the
star star does not orbit the Earth
and then the social [ __ ] of the
Copernican revolution could do to
egocentrism what the astronomical
version did to its anagram at cousin
geocentrism make someone else the
central star of our lives Wow
okay said of ourselves make someone else
the center a central star of our lives
Pass ever suggest that trying to get
people to understand that we might not
be the center of the universe is
non-trivial self centrism hasn't any
appeal that other centrism can only Envy
yes tough when defending an underdog
position in a memetic parallax Galileo
stay exemplifies the perils of
resistance against self-dealing
self-expanding beasts these metaphorical
beasts refer to socio-political economic
institutions that self expand through
extract of capitalism such as the health
care system big food in fake news is
there another way for an underdog to win
without throwing stones fighting through
the resistance and alienating or being
alienated by the very opponent they're
trying to persuade
it's very important because we can
potentially make the code updates in a
way that is peaceful and so we'll get to
that in a bit
first order of business then is to
create a system of inclusive stakeholder
need to replace inclusive fitness is the
fundamental social contract of humanity
shifting cultural norms cultural
reprogramming from egocentrism to
interdependence through linguistic
intervention the creation of propagation
of new words and cultural concepts
cultural reprogramming through expanding
the field of psychology from the current
first-person perspective to include
second and third person perspectives
cultural reprogramming through a channel
of trust packaging messages in music
subverts the inherent neuro reflex that
detects whether the message is coming
from someone familiar such as kin this
is interdependent stakeholders so okay
linguistic inventions these neologisms
and also packaging messages in music
okay
an applied Aikido principle to power the
tools rather than fighting against the
forces that established current
conditions in other words we're
optimistic that the existing forces
driving the self culture can be
redirected to a self-driving revolution
against the culture of self
self-centeredness in the ancient
tradition of the aura bourse let the
snake eat itself
so redirect the energy of the extractive
and manipulative parts of the code
redirected to have it eat itself
so far good with the reprogramming and
going through the book very interesting
to be sharing this with you thank you
again for tuning into it chapter 10
independence and interdependence the
Declaration of Independence was no doubt
monumental event but how do we reconcile
the celebration of Independence with the
reality that a quarter millennium later
Britain is now close ally in the
emerging global village does it make
sense to keep throwing parades about
signing divorce papers when we are in
fact living together again indeed all
nations today are living together in a
highly interconnected world our fates
are intertwined as individuals and
nations like never before from
ecological impact interdigitate
digitated financial systems we all have
a collective interest in managing the
risks and opportunities across the
planet
here are some fundamental questions are
we going to use the connectivity to
scale our localized self-dealing
extractive behaviors to the global level
or are we going to use the global
connectivity to spread the very best of
our human values whatever we do the
stakes have never been higher our minds
tendency to espouse separatism the way
we did with separation of good and evil
is the greatest existential threat to
our future on the other hand embracing
interdependence may be our most
significant existential hope imagine a
global holiday called interdependence
day and interdependence day happy
interdependence day across the world
that would be great let's start the
movement to make that happen which day
do we want that what day should we pick
and start the movement shared around the
world
all right chapter 11 psychology 2.0 here
comes some mini ologists understanding
habits of the mind and how they can help
shape behaviors for starters we need to
get out of our own heads
the obsession was selfhood solidarities
triumph over solidarity the cultural
reprogramming of our social contract
begins with extending the field
psychology from the first person to
perspective the one that also includes
second and third person perspectives
it's a very good table here check out
okay the zero-sum game mentality of all
witness the former's a happy feeling
caused by another's misfortune mm-hmm
okay leave that shot in fruit and the
ladder is a sad feeling caused by
another success
Andy
Freud and shot it
meanwhile compassionate is the sadness
we feel for the suffering of another
person compassion what then is the term
for a person experiencing happiness for
the success of another person right here
what is that
exactly
if you were to ask this a room
containing 100 people would be a small
miracle if one person called out the
word compersion a word for the feeling
is elusive in other cultures Assam has
remained unnamed in many languages most
Buddhists for example are far unfamiliar
with the word mudita which describes the
Buddhist concept of vicarious joy
compersion such a beautiful word posted
about it today compersion feeling joyful
from another's experience of joy how
beautiful is that you need to expand our
neologisms compersion compersion parents
experience of their children parents
experienced a quiet and sometimes not so
quiet joy when the child succeeds this
is encoded this emotional response as a
reward reflex to promote inclusive
fitness
compersion compassion of the inherent
psychological dynamics when there is
high alignment imagine if we could
promote the word compersion to that
level of familiarity in high regard that
would make us happy
let's get that word out share the word
compersion with more people around the
world have joy when someone else
experiences joy go give them a hug from
a high-five get excited about it they
share that with people share this word
compersion build these neologisms for
the psychology 2.0 era
we know a lot about envy we don't know
how much about the psychology of wanting
to be envied or wanting to be popular
we don't have word for that feeling
similarly no English word precisely
captures the traits of seeking
compassion seeking to be understood
seeking validation or seeking to be the
object of curiosity
these are definitional phrases awaiting
the invention of precise neologisms
again let's create those system
psychology psychology 2.0 are inclusive
psychology
it means hugely underdeveloped we can
kick-start inclusive psychology by
starting to name the basic second and
third person psychological phenomenon
described above assigning neologisms to
phenomena has a way of creating
consciousness so cultural shift is
possible by creating a lexicon that
makes us more cautious and mindful of
the experience of others yeah
the definition of leadership is to
steward the leadership potential of
others and this is what we write on our
materialist simulation inspires you to
build the future we inspire you to build
the future to update the code of our
world
here's an example think about the
Warworld issues and find a way to turn a
vase statement into a nice statement
this can turn depressing third person
situation into a personal responsibility
in action for example California is not
doing enough to keep the highways clean
can be restated as I need to adopt my
neighborhood highway so I can keep it
clean boom the reverse process is cool
too when something good happens turn an
i statement into a you statement I
scored the game-winning goal becomes
your pass led to the game-winning goal
in many ways that's how I feel about Ron
is that Ron's assist with this his
co-creation with this is why we're able
to build simulation these processes help
us look for people to appreciate and we
can begin to include others in our story
words have the power to shape our
culture and we have the power to create
new words and create new uses of
existing words that can help shift our
psychological frame from individuality
to interdependence
speaking of leaders in his inaugural
address president JFK Joff kitty
beseeched his countrymen ask not what
your country can do for you ask what you
can do for your country
there's thus in the throes of the Cold
War and another conflict that was
heating up that Kennedy launched the
Peace Corps
pre-new for kevin cultural program
through psychology 2.0 is one thing it's
another thing to entirely drive their
adoption unfamiliar concepts tend to
elicit suspicion and skepticism how do
we break through such psychological
barriers to adoption
music music chapter 12 mother's voice
okay 50 years ago Jeremy's grandfather
Seung Heon appeared on Walter Cronkite's
national TV program due to his work of
inserting public education into pop
songs work that later landed him a
career at the World Bank where he
collaborated with musicians around the
globe to create positive social change
sir approval we already know in our
hearts that music can change the world
this is interesting with the youn family
the lineage has been happening for so
long with Joon Young's father and now
Joon Young's son Jeremy the power of
music to spread really important
messages
this is a good challenge for us all
create the neologisms
with our psychology 2.0 create the new
social fabric of inclusive stake holding
for the global kin village as well as
create the music write the lyrics to the
music yourselves play the instruments
yourselves make the new music
a song is among the oldest forms of
communication in nature older than human
language and even older than humans
music today feels commodified
neuroscience has shown that people
respond to the same message differently
depending on the context who said it the
tone of voice and so on
making a request into the right ear got
far more positive responses than making
the same request in the left ear humor
and music also allow an audience to
engage with the message through
different pathways in the brain than do
words alone music is particularly
effective way to bypass mental defenses
against messages familiar music
activates the same neural emotional
primal reward reflexes when a baby hears
a mom's voice a critical source of
emotional comfort and social learning
ah
fake News's olds biology as mentioned
earlier the most important thing about a
message is who gives it to you mom may
not know best but she cares about you
most by virtue of Hamilton's rule that's
why evolution wired us to trust our
mothers voice more than any other voice
not because she has the best information
but because she cares about us on
average more than anyone else does
as the saying goes life doesn't come
with a manual it comes with a bomb
the unconditional love of mom imagine
programming that into our society at
large
songs once served as a unique acoustic
fingerprint of a family member now they
are industrially replicated to draw your
affection and attention familiar musics
ability to trigger the same neural
reward reflex as hearing one's mother's
voice can be used reshape culture in a
positive direction of it
people tend to sing along to songs they
hear which reinforces the messages and
people like to sing together which
spreads messages think about that very
powerful way of disseminating the music
people like to sing together it is
more resonant that way more popular that
way spreads the messages that way and
keeping up with Aikido principle global
connectivity the very force that's
challenging human values can spread the
very best of our human values through
music
all right interdependent capitalism man
is born free and everywhere he is in
Chains
it's a ought to be about the lack of
mutual vested interest right now this is
the debate
if mutually vested interest is properly
designed as the social contract in an
independent interdependent Network man's
innate tendency to pursue self-interest
can be harnessed to work for mutual
benefit rather than extraction that is
social
algorithms for inclusive steak holding
can be designed to mimic the bio
algorithms of inclusive fitness goal
congruence increases with the degree of
mutually vested interest this is you be
a universal base gases things like this
inclusive steak holding can we tie the
success of teachers to that or their
pupils can we tie the success of health
insurance food and media companies in
every industry to that of their
customers as well as the public interest
can we tie the success of elected
officials to that of their constituents
can we find ways to include the
environment future generations and
others with the out of voice as
stakeholders can we redesign physical
and online communities around the right
mix of diversity and common interest the
weight in drives once did this recent
emergence of blockchain technology and
other related technologies represents an
unprecedent platform to instantiate this
vision to create vested interest among
interdependent stakeholders goosal view
defined the way inclusive fitness tip
fork in tribes it would be akin to
taking the notion of employee stock
options common stock options common in
Silicon Valley companies and extending
it to users consumers and other
stakeholders we've talked about this on
the show so much is that it's not just
the founders of the company that raised
the capital from people that hire the
employees that build the company but
it's all the people that buy and use the
products that also deserve to be
shareholders and stakeholders what about
where the company is headquartered in
the city that its headquarter doesn't
that community also deserve also part of
the economic partaking in things so how
do we distribute the profit if the cost
of something that you make is this much
and then you're trying to profit this
much how do we distribute those to be
more fair versus if the cost of the
product is this much and you only profit
this much maybe you don't need to
distribute so much of it so it's all
these kinds of questions to look at
all right
we may not be able to count on personal
agency to over I people's hardwired
tendency to self deal we believe the key
will be in creating new social contracts
that give people vested interest in the
success of others boom
in other words the diversity of
competing interests like alignment of
interest is a feature not silly a bug of
complex social systems
bottom up philosophy that each community
when properly incentivized to do so is
in the best position to create incentive
structures that serve the greatest good
launched an incentive price this is a
big part of their initiative on
inclusive stake holding okay they've
launched an incentive price for
incentives to develop a new model called
interdependent capitalism aka
interdependent stake holding competition
is a national force of social system we
are leveraging this force to nurture the
best ideas for social innovation on
incentives well first if Fuller said you
never change things by fighting the
existing reality to change something
build a new model that makes the
existing model obsolete
whereas misalignment with competition is
race to the bottom alignment with
competition is a race to the top okay
again remember there's an initiative on
inclusive stake holding launched an
incentive price for incentives to
develop a new model called
interdependent capitalism so you can
partake in this create your own models
around interdependent capitalism so
submit them to this incentive price it's
a very good way to get involved and get
your community involved your ideas out
there
chapter 14 welcome home evolution
selected our innate social instincts
including altruistic behaviors to align
with kin based social systems it
probably was difficult for early humans
to avoid living in kin tribes the
fitness value of 10 based living was too
high as was the cost of avoiding it
indeed higher-order cognition that
overrides innate instincts might even
have interfered with fitness
maximization human size during the kin
tribe era left us no record perhaps life
for them just wise
somewhere along the way we humans became
seduced by knowledge including the
knowledge of how to harness energy and
make tools that knowledge of bruited
humans from our kin tribes the senate's
battled and were banished to a life of
wandering Dysport began feed-forward
accrual of knowledge and journeys the
dispersion in diaspora hit their
planetary limits and the low align
lineages merged and remixed
civilizations began to rise and fall the
rising tide that has buoyed us
materially has unmoored a spiritually
way to many parts of the human
experience feel solace
it's time to restart at your zero the
purpose of this book is not to swing the
pendulum of human endeavor from
self-dealing to self-sacrifice the truth
of human nature lives more than the deep
and enduring tension that exists between
these extremes than in the extremes
themselves and that's how we speak so
much about how the binary versus all of
the great nuance and gray area
the truth of our human nature lives
there our story is that our lives all of
our lives are best served by
encompassing some mix of both modes of
living in lane self-interest as a social
code works best when we also have a
vested interest in each other's lives
most importantly going forward we have
the opportunity to reinvent our
institutions based on inclusive stake
holding goal congruence invested
interest in the success of others
attributes that were inherent in the
inclusive fitness of our prehistoric
social systems we are now stewarding
each other's journeys homeward instead
of a world in which history is written
by the victors imaginal world in which
history is made by helping others win
history being made by helping others win
all right in that block The Tree of Life
is a mythological archetype that appears
throughout the world's religious and
philosophical traditions a branching
tree is also plays a metaphor for
evolutionary speciation blotching Forks
and many other systems are future
implications what is a branch point in a
tree analogous to memetic parallax that
branch plane is where ramification and
division occurs industry common central
trunk bifurcates into separate limbs
which by forgettings of branches the
process repeats iteratively until the
tips of the leaves fractal recursion is
evident tree of life can also serve as a
metaphor for the Diaspora of a kin hive
over generations from a central share
trunk kin lineage iteratively bifurcates
in repeating patterns over time the
further downstream from the central
chunk the more distant the cousins
leaf genome sequences on an individual
tree were not found to be identical they
varied systemically out as a gradient
from the bottom to the top of the tree
thus the genetic variance among branches
increases along with the degree of
ramification these Shree exhibits micro
chimerism if the limbs of a tree are
seen as a collection of conjoined
cousins when one cousin dies the
remaining branch has not only survived
they thrive
a human cancer cell then is a division
gone rogue a cancer cell can subvert
existing host pathways and hijack them
to self deal at the expense of the host
the cancer becomes a self expanding
beast that feeds on the host a former
community member that grows by feeding
off the community the pair lost
institutions in our society today are
self-evident what institutions are
cancerous
by some degree of competition overall
goal congruence invested interest in
each other success the distal branches
can be thought of as genetically
different cousins who compete with each
other for resources from the central
trunk below they grow upward and past
each other competing for some light from
above
and distal leaves are as benign as
Little League baseball enough
competitive dynamic to help nurture the
selection of beneficial traits among the
distally fee cousins but not enough
competition to truly hurt each other one
thing one can think of competition for
resources from the trunk is competition
for mother's attention and one can think
of vertical competition for sunlight s
competition for father's attention but
the competition is subordinate to their
shared fate of interdependence Sherriff
aid of interdependence plus the
competition for collaborative
competition
for everything to be won there can be no
end to the oneness the concept of a
unifying oneness can only exist as an f
Forenza infinite loop
people aren't good or evil everyone is
good and evil
the gift that drives transformation
the curse of human dualities the
conflicts many capitals over socialism
give the drive transformation
these dualities drive transformation
a circle is the essence of duality the
self-feeding beast turns out to be a
self consuming serpent that has nothing
other than the circle of life itself
this is where he begins so that's that
block and then within the related essays
there is a couple really important
points here that I think we need to
bring up summarize things 10 altruism -
reciprocal altruism to the global King
village
kind of like the evolution
every steps that we've taken
so we've had a shift from predominately
based on kin altruism to one based on
reciprocal altruism during the kin tribe
area we could generally rely on others
acting with our best interests at heart
without performing an undue amount of
due diligence
counterparty risk is far higher among
genetic strangers than genetic relatives
what if the shift from living in can be
social systems to living in communities
of strangers which lowers genetic
alignment and increases counterparty
risk was a forcing function in the
acceleration of advanced symbolic
systems such as language very
interesting point when genetic Lyman is
higher the need to negotiate is lower
when alignment is low interactions
require greater degree of negotiation
so the slope fragmentation of our ten
tribes created a higher degree of need
to negotiate which could have led to the
development of language potentially
compressive scales represent quantities
according to relevance when something is
scarce such as bananas and winter time
being able to discriminate between the
quantities one in two matters on the
other hand there is no fitness relevance
to being able to distinguish between
high number such as 280 and 281 bananas
for example spending twenty five
thousand dollars for a car versa twenty
four thousand dollars is a huge
discrepancy for a customer with a net
worth of thirty thousand it is vital
that the consumer senses the one
thousand dollar difference a linear
scale enables this sensing far better
than a compressive scale
the development of linear skills
catalyzed trade among counterparties
reciprocal altruism
invention the small clay tokens the
oldest known human systems for counting
around 4000 BC so about the 6,000 years
ago pictographs on tablets representing
numerals developed to facilitate
transactions commodities Sumerians
invented arithmetic including addition
subtraction multiplication division to
manage their grain trade thereafter more
and more advanced mathematics began to
emerge linear mathematics has proven
it's worth high resolution at high
numbers is the only way to create the
kind of precision at high numbers that
would allow us to land a rocket far away
on the moon
notice that everything in nature curves
and all the straight lines you see are
man-made
black swans tend to get underpriced as a
result
individuals experience the world based
on the language they habitually use
experience the world in a far richer
fashion and develop advanced thoughts
so this is the the development of
elaborate lingual just helped us
experience a while on the far richer
fashion develop advanced thoughts
a broader interpretation of theory of
linguistic relativity suggests that
naming words promotes consciousness
through awareness a transitivity those
who spell such a view could make the
case that the transition of human social
systems from inclusive fitness to
reciprocal altruism may have been a
forcing function for the emergence of
human consciousness
Wow
from inclusive fitness to reciprocal
altruism might have been forcing
function for the emergence of this come
more complex human consciousness things
things like language potentially
from individuals like perspective
children have no subjective memory of
the time before they could name things
fractally from the perspective of the
species humans have no recorded memory
of the time before the emergence of
symbolic systems all right very
important section here mimetic palette
parallax and mob mentality binary
divisions either-or choices and various
types of polarization aren't a bug of
human social software they're a feature
think about it what comes immediately
after world peace civil war why from
multi-level selection perspective
evolution selects for systems with
features that increase evolutionary
capacity in perfect replication sexual
reproduction predation programmed death
mimetics etc add to this list of memetic
parallax which is the tendency of meme
groups to diverge into competing views
so this is like parallax / consensus but
in a balanced way
the tendency toward groupthink driven by
mimetic algorithms can trap systems in
local minima in the adaptive landscape
that impede evolutionary novelty in
constrained fitness
diversity and conflict with an assistant
promotes system robustness and
evolutionary capacity selection favor
systems that generate feature parallax
diversity / consensus especially when it
promotes conflict to a degree that
optimizes competition and accelerates
evolution
Darwinian arms race for features related
to mobility evasion defense perception
weapons communication social behaviors
and further evolutionary novelty a
second opinion from a trusted partner is
a significant value add in partnerships
teams and marriages
when facing a common external enemy we
tend to settle our internal disputes and
unite against enemy until a larger
consensus peace results once the enemy
is dissipated mimetic parallax
reemergence the victors of world with
two entered peace discussions of the
spirit of international cooperation and
exited with divergent agendas but
continued parallax and over
fragmentation are also costly das vs.
them campaigns
selection favors dynamic systems capable
of both consensus mimetics and mimetic
parallax in a context of dependent
fashion a fractal as a parent the
tendency for groupthink and the tendency
for parallax peace will follow war and
the war would follow peace and so on
hive mentality can be transformed into
it's dangerous alter ego mob mentality
a delusional disorder in which
individuals incorrectly believe they are
infested with parasites often
compulsively gathering evidence to
present to others witch hunts fall into
this category too
groupthink is an evolutionary win for
both the individual and the
superorganism rearing offspring shared
defense resource acquisition migration
communication all work better in a kin
based group prehistoric times tribal
beliefs who might call mimetic
affiliation today corporate culture or
patriotism
that point mom mentality of the super
arson can own the minds of the
individuals who lose their capacity for
intellectual honesty in the hallmark of
someone under the spell of a dangerous
mob in many ways some of the employees
at some of the larger corporations
potentially feel this way and they need
their ability to speak up some sometimes
they almost can't when you change that
culture then betted growth obligations
that these organizations need to change
as well are they serving society quite
well nuanced discourse around a
groupthink and mob behavior are
everywhere they are a defining feature
of life and subconsciously influence our
everyday behavior far more than we
realize
seems some balance of competing
interests and alignment of interest
within social groups maximizes
evolutionary fitness it's very important
for you sir what is that balance
including weapons of mass destruction
nuclear weapons and weapons of mass
destruction extract media diversity
without common ground creates separatism
separatism with mob mentality promotes
polarization polarization plus advanced
weaponry leads to a people evolution did
not anticipate an era in which mimetic
super organisms could form around memes
that serve the interests of the super
organism self but not serve the
interests of the individuals that
comprise the organism super organism
and related essay three reimagining
fairytales the institutions we built to
attack the self-expanding beasts in one
area become a self expanding piece of
the next restoring the alignment of
interests in our communities
interdependent stake holding through
innovations such as blockchain and
cultural reprogramming to promote
self-driving revolutions that will
steward the world to a better place
story memes are more efficient than
jeans and transferring traits
horizontally within a generation
vertically across generations even
across great gaps of space and time this
is why we prioritize mimetics mimetics
mimetics so important powerful story
means for that inclusive fitness for
example the death of a parent is one of
the most transformative moments and
evolutionary fitness of their offspring
as stories our bure eyes through
retelling they mutate the diverse
versions of a particular story compete
among themselves for audience attention
the loudest shake in the next gets the
attention that is instead of telling a
story but even the best interest of the
listener people started to tell stories
to promote their own interests a major
issue with that me a story tell for
promoting the global kin village not for
just self dealing
one skin genetic alignment is gone and
the defenses are down the coevolution of
story storytellers and story listeners
selects for the high-fructose corn
service stories and storytellers be wary
of such self-dealing storytellers
they're accomplices in their industries
entertainment publishing podcast media
speaker series etc
that is race to the bottom nature of
misalign systems induces ongoing
mutations of stories towards commercial
success rather than to service the
community
the key features of courtly love are
honor sacrifice chivalry service and
valor ideals that our view to skepticism
if not laugh oh I'll do vision in
today's culture and ideal of courtly
love however these sacrificial features
are expressed on sarcastically and
unconditionally
a hero instinct is deeply embedded in
the male psyche and even encoded in male
genes
fundamental point is that an ongoing
drama of biological evolution females do
more than procreate they choose females
choose a key female contribution to the
evolutionary progress is trade selection
through make choice females choose mate
choice trying to say this for so long
two females hold enormous power they not
only help surface genetically wired
instincts of valor and service in males
they can also actively help select those
genetically encoded traits for the
propagation of her lineage huge
transparent to transcendence
transcendence is something that ensues
after recognizing that the world of
phenomena is a merely an expression of
an underlying eternal source
first in the heroes during tempo the
good about quarters are typically
segregated in the characters in the real
world everybody is a mix of good and bad
and folktales people are either good or
bad
that is the characters are painted as
black or white instead of gray there's
an Sidious reason why these features
were selected they maximize audience
attention
the hero's journey is a self-help
narrative that fits the mimetic priming
induced by rising mutual alienation over
the millennia damn our tendency to think
about others through the lens of
separatism of thinking trained and
reinforced by the black-and-white nature
fairy tales is the foundation of us
versus them thinking
yep that nuance that gray area everyone
polarization through mimetic parallax is
the is existential threat of our time
worse the race to the bottom nature of
the mimetic marketplace selects for the
most polarizing versions of stories we
argue that this phenomena of corrupted
storytelling has been happening since we
left the area of kin tribes however the
phenomenon appears to be accelerating in
the modern world self-dealing media
including those that used extractive
algorithms are driving the world towards
sectionalism gender wars
race Wars political polarization witch
hunts and every other type of extremism
a mob attack people are finally
beginning to see it we're able to see
the extremism and the separatism and the
polarization when we really need to be
able to have some cooperation with the
competition that we have in the ideas
both at the same time
stories once served ten tribes once we
shifted to low alignment community
storytellers interest shifted to seeking
secondary gain for themselves stories
became commodified
in other words the hero's journey is the
high fructose corn syrup of stories
and there's so much about hero's journey
that's been propagated but that's a
pretty powerful statement high-fructose
corn syrup a stories mean that nuanced
not just good and evil
to escape the seemingly endless game of
institutional whack-a-mole in which we
appear to be trapped duality is the
reality each of us a simultaneously hero
and the antihero
imagine if the aim of our journey is to
steward each other's journeys we believe
this is the fairy tale of the kin tribe
era we believe this was the original
love story this was also the original
hero's journey we are never just a hero
or just the antihero we are a hybrid of
the two
holding competing moral thoughts is not
easy it's critical and that our hero's
journeys are to steward each other's
journeys our hero's journeys are to
steward each other's journeys inspiring
you to build the future you inspire us
to build the future we work together
this very important will create the
patronage culture that we help lift you
up you help lift us up we keep doing
that with each other around the world
all right final word we say the word
stick it to the man is an idiomatic
expression of defiance against these
forces of oppression but the man is
actually us
nothing can be Oh all that is it's not
it's not meant to be a perfect
expression of the counterculture to all
that is oppressing people nothing can be
burning man nonetheless remains the most
intriguing attempt to break the
oligopoly that self-expanding beasts
have on culture and the human experience
they mean can actually you know June's
has been to Burning Man the past 19
years so
to have a bit about that here welcome
home strange thing to say to someone
you've just met this is that Burning Man
culture and San Francisco incorporated
itself in 1850 to accommodate this
influx of unwashed entrepreneurs goal
there's time stories from those early
years suggests that it was a bit of a
free-for-all and it collected random mix
adventurers from all walks of life
trying to build a city from scratch in a
short period of time
there's no contest San Francisco spawned
the computing revolution the hippie
revolution the venture capital
Revolution the gay revolution the
biotech revolution internet revolution
the revolutionary idea that young people
can start companies the social media
revolution in the blockchain revolution
all these phenomena have gone global
so I Silicon Valley such an important
place to come and be and visit and
explore and understand
Burning Man is an example the hadn't
been for city cop telling Larry Harvey
to take his Baker beach fire hazard on
the road he never would have discovered
Black Rock City
and that's the creating the experimental
civilization
it is the basis of our faith that humans
will eventually at some distant time
solve everything whatever that means
what will we do after we solve
everything including longevity space
travel world peace and interdependence
take holding we probably do then exactly
we had been doing it's helped
proximately 10,000 years ago gather
around the fire tell stories and dance
this is what we have done since the
beginning of time and will do until the
end of time there's probably more nuance
to that there's a lot that's gonna
happen in the designer virtual worlds
and in the simulations and create and
all that kind of stuff and digitizing
consciousness house we can do that how
it's gonna happen all that stuff
nothing's impossible but our imagination
is it was unbounded there's so much to
explore send during humans story that
stretches in both directions outside the
current twenty thousand year grand
interlude the only strange epoch in
human history where we got caught up in
the belly of the beast
Burning Man then is that rare glimpse
into the timeless and accessible life
outside of the grand interlude being in
this otherworldly place called Burning
Man will feel like being home
so some more information about Junoon
Jeremy Ewan and Conrad you
and here's the back of a cover - should
we check out again that's the blurb we
read at the beginning and then this is
June Jeremy Jones here Jeremy Shearer
Conrad's here
and again the book is interdependent
capitalism such fantastic book again by
the Yoon Family Foundation June Jeremy
and Conrad Yoon again this beautiful yin
and yang with the tree the leaves as
well as the roots and redesigning the
social contract through inclusive steak
holding alright huge thank you everyone
for tuning in to this episode greatly
appreciated it's been a long one we've
been doing a book review of
interdependent capitalism we would love
to hear your thoughts in the comments
below on this book review and about
intertube interdependent capitalism we
would also love for you to check out the
links below to the interdependent
capitalism com the Amazon book link Palo
Alto Institute dr. June's website all of
those links below have more
conversations with your friends your
co-workers people online on social media
about your family about interdependent
capitalism about the new inclusive
fitness at on the global village level
and about building the technologies that
we need to get there about building out
the blockchain technologies about
building out the music technologies
maybe it's you that's gonna be singing
or you that's playing the instrument or
you that's gonna be doing the psychology
2.0 neologisms we need all these
different pieces to the puzzle we need
to figure out how to work better with
our social economic and political fabric
with our corporations and our
governments to get rid of fake news fake
food and fake politicians and bring in
the the right incentive structures that
propagate a global cohesive stake
holding interdependent fabric so let's
get talking more about that everyone let
me know what you thought about this book
review and what you think about book
reviews in general how you'd like me to
handle them in the future we'd love to
hear from you about that and this is all
up to us everyone support organizations
like simulation if you believe in what
we do all of our links are below help
support us scale and grow an impact
build the future everyone manifest these
dreams into the world we got this
collect
we together we can do this huge shout
out to Joon Yoon in the UN family
foundation love you all you're huge
mentors of mine this is one of the best
books I've ever read everyone check it
out huge thank you and we'll see you
soon
much love peace